i had the good fortune of taping a
podcast with you
i want to say about a month and a half
ago and it was absolutely
you were hilarious you were not it was
non-stop laughs the whole time
and i think we spent all of it talking
about your mom yeah your mom is taking
over
um obviously she's a big part in your
life but she
seems to have become a phenomenon in her
own right now
yeah she she she has become man you know
um and you know this was always her
dream conan
you know to do what we're doing yeah and
to do what she's doing now
and it never panned out for her main
reason she's a horrible actress and
really
doesn't have the talent
nor the discipline that it takes to make
it right um
here's the issue the issue is she's
showing up in places i wouldn't expect
your mom to show up
she's on social media she posted
uh a tick tock silhouette challenge
and i first of all i'm if i went on
tick-tock i stay off tick-tock because
my kids would just
be they would disown me if i went on
tick-tock no one wants to see me on
tick-tock
your mom is killing it on tick-tock she
is
man uh i had posted it on on my social
media page man and it got
you know close to a hundred and fifty
two thousand views
and that was right i love that you know
my my mom is doing her thing
now wait a minute let's let's show it we
have a clip here
of your mom's tick tock challenge this
is a silhouette
challenge i guess it's called yeah it's
a silhouette challenge now let's take a
look at this and see what's going on
playing her favorite game bingo baby
baby baby
[Laughter]
she's grabbing her nipples right now
they're down around her waist yeah
they're down around her way oh now she
put him back up on her shoulders
[Laughter]
look at that little dip
now wait a minute wait a minute first of
all uh that was very entertaining
second of all when it cuts to the
silhouette i know it's supposed to be
kind of erotic and sexy i was also
frightened
it had like a it had a horror movie vibe
about it
well it was horror-like as a son
watching that not knowing my mother not
knowing what she was about to expose or
show
and you know i don't know uh first of
all how does she even
know about this a mom your mom my mom
they're not supposed to know about this
[ __ ] well my mom
is a young 67 man she still has her ear
to the street she uh rarely hangs around
people her age
uh and and just likes to be amongst the
people man you know
uh we have lots of cousins a young
cousin she has
lots of young nieces and nephews that
that are around her they keep
she picks up on how young people speak
how they behave she's
she's picking up on all that she's
picking up on that man i remember one
time i was telling her to meet me
someplace
and she was like what time i need to be
there i was like he's like say less i
was like whoa whoa
whoa whoa who you've been talking to
say less i love that yeah say less salas
isn't a put down right
no it's not a put down it's like i got
you you don't need to say any more
say less right i don't think that's
going to go over at my house
when i go home and my wife says okay
well anyway i was thinking and i go
say less you're going to hear about a
homicide
a homicide conor bryan was shot and
killed today
you have to know when to work it in yeah
i would not know that yeah
yeah now is your mom is she gambling
still because i know she loves gambling
but
there's proven she started off her tick
tock playing bingo
but is she is she i know she's playing
bingo but can she can she
she can play for money she can play for
money uh they just recently
opened um uh her bingo hall this past
monday
so she's back oh so what has she been
how has you been playing bingo
while the bingo hall the bingo hall must
have been closed for a year the bingo
hall has been closed for a year
uh she found this place out in rosemead
uh
where they converted a drive-in to
drive-in bingo
you roll up in your car they give you a
pad and they give you your
um your your daubers or or your uh
your placemats to play and uh
they uh would read the numbers and it
would come over the radio station like
you know the movies
yeah yeah and if you got a bingo you lay
it on your horn and then they would come
over and check your car
bingo [ __ ]
and they would just come on over there
like yeah she bingo
she got she got it you know i gotta say
that maybe should continue even after
everyone's vaccination
even after everyone's vaccinated right i
i i should keep doing it that way
i would love to go to drive in bingo man
with my mom yeah the idea of leaning on
the horn
yeah yeah yeah that that's fascinating
she invited me but i was like nah i'm
cool
yeah yeah you've got other things to do
i got other things to do